real stuff right back I think I just
grew bowls on my bowls hey what's going
on everybody prefers to be feast I'm
Sean Evans and you're watching hot ones
it's the show without questions and even
hotter wings and today I'm joined by one
of the biggest pop stars in the world
Liam Payne it was a little group called
one direction perhaps you've heard of
them as debut single stripped down
without now stream it download it it's a
banger Liam
welcome to the show thank you thanks
having me I've worn cream in preparation
to still spoon of sauce upon myself I
was going to say it's a little age yeah
I think it is but I don't feel like
maybe I am quite messy which it can be
sometimes how are you with hot food when
you go to Nando's develop I like hot
booze the insides that doesn't like food
it's like when people say the inside
counts it really does in this situation
means I'd definitely does count are you
ready to see what you have inside so I'm
just going to look yeah we got I mean we
got our stuff the last day are but that
could be the last end to be a pop dab in
Korea
[Music]
Oh Dean you do we could make a noose a
new song to be anyway what do you want
to know well first congratulations on
becoming a proper dad thank you a real
life real life one have you learned
anything from trading notes with fellow
first-time father Russell Brand's we
even read trade notes you were just
talking about people look to you horror
stories
no parents out there in the parenting
game to help other parents they just
look to scare you
we got our baby bear into a sleeping
pattern in like seven weeks they want
hates on us - the lifestyle my kids like
three months old and he still can't
sleep like an hour they go or you must
be tired then well I will actually I'm
getting a lot more things than usual and
then like all but that will change but I
don't want you to do that if they don't
want to see us do well it's kind of as
can even say as part of the games called
life trial and tribulation it never
sells into the world that good wings oh
this is what's nice about it by the way
this is breakfast this is the first
thing I think that I should have lined
my stomach somehow before I got here
is breakfast for five years pretty much
non-stop you spend all your time with
these guys from one direction from the
stage to the hotel suite to the tour bus
who is the messiest roommate hmm I mean
Louie was always the messiest you just
find that random socks and stuff around
places just random stuff stroll along
the bus leaves a trail yes over the
years who have you seen cry physically
cry the most
Harry how do you cry when we first got
sodium it many times are happy to you
who is the most fun to have a cheeky
beer with cheats beer
I'd say knowing that nada likes a cheeky
beer now Reese after now I looked at
this I looked upon this guy earlier on I
mean he's got quite a cute picture going
on their knees looks like he's enjoying
himself a little sauce dolls well I'm
gonna let him know what I think after
this
[Music]
- strange hot sauce has too much sauce a
so for most your adult life you've been
shadowed by maybe the most passionate
global audience and music and I'm sure
you have a million stories about all the
crazy bass to face interactions when you
think about all the insane things that
people have done to try to get your
attention is there a story that stands
out but I mean typical this is one we
always said about this girl who's jump
job attractions like trying to our
attention
supposed to be different funny signs of
people do let's try and get my things
I'm a fidget spinners have become a
thing to get my attention remember
because I was showing off my spinning
skills so we got one in the back
somewhere and so I fidget least BAM
marcantel we're getting hot we're going
into heat down oh yeah that one's like
never know at least respite sometimes
they can hurt different parts of avast
that's a very insightful thing to say
Lea and a lot of people don't know that
but that's true you know the Chili's the
peppers they all hit you kinda
differently so a habanero might hit you
differently than they do like so
sometimes they that one's definitely
like the front of the tongue he's like
mm-hmm
that's tantalizing the tone but eaten
lips so here at first we FIFA obsessed
with Diddy stories you told a great one
when you have a grandeur to show
recently yes I don't know about you but
when I make an awkward first impression
I play it over in my head
yeah you just wonder what could I have
done differently but I don't know in
that scenario I just offered out a
friendly hand and I just was great
advice did he's low steady laugh oh I
was the wit motive weird experience and
the handshake just didn't seem to end
balanced that wasn't pinned on us now no
good lord
the group was pretty scary it was
DiCaprio he was in obvious I don't want
to be revolver celebrity murder of God
how and please leave me alone sort of
thing and then and jay-z was just in the
middle part yeah you know
okay and then he did he would just look
like the time to start off the night
with south but you know what
no what's that over there I'm a little
shaken the - what's happening but that
takes some courage to kind of like roll
up on that crew it did take some courage
it was some courage that was it was
massively held by a little bit too much
champagne oh yeah I can go make friends
with you guys
nothing like a fun time what a crew to
be hanging out together and I noticed
not one of them was talking to each
other but they were also at the same
table what's that about oh well sit with
you and I'm going to talk about anything
which is cool to talk about stuff then I
saw sorry it's not bad doing okay so far
now that that one's right at the back of
the throat dancing now come think about
that what seemed like easy at the time
and now there's a small inferno at the
back of my throat is happening Liam I'm
noticing a trend it seems like you're
sort of putting the carriage in front of
the horses you know what I mean yeah I'm
getting ahead of myself feeling like I'm
like always covered
well I've been trying to really chew a
digest and just to make sure that I
understand how hot is this before he
goes that way sometimes you did like I
say you don't know you don't know it
it's gonna eat you they're right they
didn't want us to do this alright we
have a recurring segment on our show
called explain that Graham and what we
do is we do a deep dive and our guests
Instagram and we pull interesting
pictures that need more context so I'll
show you the picture and then you just
tell me the bigger story she's not a
regret things that I say so I get
another napkin that's nice thank you
this is the heart this is the hard time
napkin you never know what's going on
here okay so we were outside one of our
I'm somewhere in front of houses and
knowledge to start this car the most
obvious part of it is yes we trashed his
car this small tail area teddy bear
reading the magazine has have been on
top and any form of garden furniture or
item that we could find to throw on top
of this car happened but then when I
treated the picture I do blur out is his
red plate so now all the fans could
track his car no matter what we did to
the car the worst barbers have just that
little simple white box in the middle so
then he was that was a he was tracked
for days I feel being tracked now
doing for all you guys work together for
a couple days or problem we find it
we've almost come for the same sort of
oh now we have no I've gone for the
finger-pointing that's welcome for in
that one yeah we were you spending a
little bit of time working together now
how many men do you know they can pull
off that outfit one him exactly i came
wearing different civil time I was
thinking like I wish I was that guy you
can just wear everything one more for
you this is me and drag me and Drake in
the glove which is so funny because I we
got thrown out of this party but if you
did we take how does the unpainted hey
we I'm not running I won't go into our
own digest DJ was it the human for us at
personally once again it's always the
personnel personnel because I like none
of our tea for quite gracious gracious
host I would say where these people were
not so gracious and and in the end that
was it we would run out the PI just
wanted to use all want to know so much
more use all anyone's like mmm that's
all I get
I probably already say too much we watch
this one this is dirty dicks aggressor
yes
dirty dicks oh it smells beautiful
though
hot something entices you in it entices
you and I'm judging on your reaction and
I think on a taste level Liam I think
you'll really enjoy this wing I really
do you really do always it's like really
yeah should I quit stallin let me know I
don't know you all right
Magellan you got Mariners bars radar
those by virtue of these massive world
tours you have this rare distinction and
that you've toured the entire globe by
the age of 23 on an architectural level
what's the most stunning city you've
ever visited why one is I question there
was a place in Italy that I went to that
had this quite this big white cathedral
blasphemous I don't know whether they
were is now now that one's actually
really catching up on us now maybe it's
just a joint mixture of all of them
together that's really you don't even
know it might be the aardvarks and you
can have fun
it could be the other where the best
beaches in the world in your opinion do
you know what there was a beach when I
used to go on are they in to Florida
siesta key in a really good speech then
it was in like a magazine for being that
one of the best beaches and now it's not
so good what's the best food city in the
world in Arabic Oh your favorite food
see to me actually being in America I'm
a man of simple tastes how good our
mozzarella sticks
you love mozzarella mozzarella sticks
are just the height of all culinary
skill bright cheese with tomato stuff
little marinara dip action I'm all about
it people my nose that needs to stop
happening I've got small nose burn this
once abundant
[Music]
to kind of immediately oh wow yeah I was
talking start some real when they put
zombie enough whoa balls I'm a ball so a
number of our path I was really
confident now this is really nice just
throwing my game wow it really is quite
hot that it's happening so we've had a
number of guests have high-profile
run-ins with Donald Trump and I actually
find that his brand of celebrity feud is
endlessly fascinating what's the story
behind him punishing one direction by
kicking you guys out of one of his
hotels so the thoughts my awareness the
way this story rolls is that we were in
his hotel very nice hotel and he had
called up at like some ungodly hour
asking if we could come and meet his
door and an atomizer fight he said like
they're in bed like surely not an armed
runaway come on so then this one's
really affecting my brain power to think
bombs what the story was what really in
brain that's why they call it a zombie
and we had access to an underground
garage get out this hotel one direction
needs that is a safety thing with
sometimes for people cuz they like run
across the street especially out here in
New York they're the road to row safety
codes struggling with in this town so we
just got back there this one of just is
the gift that keeps on giving
wow I don't getting really knows that
was up and so he took out underground
carpark barrages Wayne and the guard I
was like what we need to do the safety
of everybody outside where it is for the
safety of the guy he's like I didn't
need to use the Azzaro outlined so that
was it
packed our bags and left but not by the
underground carpark that one is
yeah three more left as well I'm gonna
finish these three wings and table it
really does hurt them
[Music]
I got you they hit you a bit differently
when he said yep very smoky all right
what is different more experience before
I feel like you're getting on top of it
I actually I can't I can't read you
right now Liam I don't know where your
odd yeah it's not nice mm-hmm whoo mama
oh no no no no aah not wanting me typing
ah by the way I'll just okay that was
another pic ah that one's real mom
uh-huh your perfectly made holiday
turkeys are any indication I know that
you're not afraid to roll up your
sleeves in the kitchen but breathing
really slowly if it is nice for couples
like I do that to a Aries Aries action
I'll call breathing vlogging arrived to
breathe out again holy you are not to
swear on the show this way yeah it's the
internet you don't understand butterfly
man [ __ ] all about mamas videos if
you're to audition for Top Chef rather
than x-factor what would be your best
signature dish
oh no making it all was what is that
best me off
best meal would be I like to make like
Italian dishes so I knew like spicy
chicken IV IO which I can't even really
call spicy now carries that thing my
eyes alight with this genuine water
can't feel my toes me
[Music]
it's called Megadeth I didn't even read
the name yeah this is Blair's Megadeth
sauce whipped with liquid rage I had you
put fro Bernard Vidor why don't we and
interests feel alive at the bottom they
warn the sauce contains ingredients 500
times hotter and a jalapeno chili use
sparingly not recommended for use
without dilution did we dilute this we
did in but it's not recommended for use
to the disclaimer of the valises we're
not supposed to do this because I've
been engrained in how one is acid oh man
and once again who ever met who you ever
did this one really you went to town
where's DOM hate me where do you hate
one direction
no come on it should get in there
love it love it so I want to talk about
Watson for a second but always a dream
of yours they have a massive dark yeah
just a slob is everywhere so like you
can't wait good clothes in the house
really just that's getting fire either
one big slobbery dog what's the most
impressive trick I can I can make him
sit this is bit cool where's good food
it's good fries manners to put that way
I can get him to lie down and then I can
put like a steak on these pause while
you lay down and you will eat the steak
until I clap no matter where I am I can
leave it both stairs come right now and
he'll still just be looking mistake it's
like yeah coming yeah and then when you
clap well that big clot is gone
well yeah it's scary values how fast
[Music]
you okay thanks it's difficult at this
point to know which source is just
decided to make a reentrant and no one
in an uncle hadn't quite had enough yet
and just done the nut per second it has
taken a stun that's done as a stretch
out yeah this is the last one
uh-huh uh-huh but I've got like it I've
developed a chest infection and sinuses
all right
so this is the last down why you ask
well it's tradition around here to dab
the last wing with a little extra you
don't have to if you don't want to do
now went on amigos um which is Ricky
doesn't want it I don't want too much of
it to grow just be careful oh oh wow
okay was the I'm sticking without
respect respect Liam hmm I would tell
you this whole thing's back story but I
don't think you want to hear about it no
no no come on please Harris so the
hottest suffer in the world was the
Carolina Reapers grown by this guy named
smokin Edie he has a farm in South
Carolina called [ __ ] pot javanese
somebody made a pepper hotter than his
but little did they know that he
secretly had pepper X like in the
archives he was just waiting for
somebody to one-up him so that's made
with the pepper ax which this is pepper
eggs okay have you eaten yours not yet
oh yeah you should like cheer them
typically with embraced freshmen for
cheers a wing
I wondered up would hold on I'm going to
get that pepper ax yeah
[Music]
I never like I got out it's on him I'll
make all of me not gonna let my fingers
up with this I don't feel like I got it
I want to I want to run a sudden what
pepper X is all about
Diouf like I'm beginning to warm up them
come on when eyes are bringing about Oh
boom
[Music]
and you can tell Smokey Joe every name
was this batteries not really old at all
smoking head smoking at her dad you need
to change your first name bra collide I
just you the secret when you later you
know you get on top of a sauce you
celebrate it and then I feel like it's a
professional rest I wish I beats down
slams the chair over the back to you
alright the laptop the last down
[Music]
hey [ __ ] it's making these revival this
is smoking into the return of Ed given a
chance to walk that back would you oh
yeah yeah yeah you were on now is wrong
so now that the members of one direction
of all released solo work fans are
getting to see a different more distinct
side to all these in holding on to this
to smoke an end that's sure that's true
and even for you you get to see a
different side of all these artists you
get to see a different side Niall Louie
Harry Zayn so with the last DAP coursing
through you it's time for some truth
serum and we're getting cheeky with this
one I want you to rank these singles
from your most favorite to your least
favorite just hold on Slowhand
pillow-talk sign of the times
lit burn is real but like I might get
like called a shootout goin on an
Internet yeah little Kylie lip kit
action maybe that's what she puts in it
yeah I think she's been messing around
with Reapers for sure I'm sweaty now
that one's physically like a sweater oh
god I can't read the boys singles I
think this is a theory is that
everyone's kind of done such different
skillful now I need to sniff I don't
know it's gonna be the wrong move we're
about to find out
ah this just gets worse now I mean I
feel like you kind of like tested fate
there you know I got cocky
it happened I think it's down to each
person's musical taste is not so much
down to the idea what was best and worst
songs so don't mean there are any worse
songs so I think everybody did the best
of what they wanted to make hi Manohar
Manama
I'll tell you this it's nothing to
sneeze at Liam you made it through you
cleared the board
you look great doing it you wore a cream
Krulak which was very brave very
courageous emptied a lot of fates today
you did you went double dab on the last
dab you didn't have to but you did you
went the extra mile that's it
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life I've gone noosing Locke
will strip that down there's an album to
come if we're still alive
after the last tab I think that was good
to me
because I thought I thought I was
cheating I was like no way am i drinking
any better I'm just gonna take this on
the chin now oh [ __ ] this and now
there's a chest burns ok ok I'm changing
color hello hot ones fans Sean Evans new
outro same message if you like what you
saw throw us a bone maybe please it is
dog-eat-dog here on the YouTube streets
hit that subscribe button
knowing that you subscribed it is
seriously the only thing that gets me
out of bed in the morning thank you very
much hot ones fans I love you